[Musique]
qui est venu ici parce que c'est à
l'amour sincère
ah oui il ya deux ans derrière
merci de votre nez tu étais alors
pourquoi j'ai tout cette question parce
que on a souvent tendance à parler du
bon endroit mais ma question est celle
de savoir comment avons nous pu conclure
que tel endroit est un bon endroit
aujourd'hui on est là on est heureux
vespa en est vraiment heureux on peut
saluer son voisin merci je sens que j'en
ai rarement bon endroit
alors parlons du bon endroit
autre thème de ce soir j'ai du bol
hongrois à mon endroit
pourquoi je le dis parce que j'ai
remarqué une chose dont la plupart
toutefois nous avons tendance à conclure
que l'endroit est un panneau droit parce
que ya beaucoup de gens qui vont n'est
ce pas parce que c'est à la mode parce
que je sais pas moi on distribue de la
nourriture ou des choses qu'on aime mais
rassurez vous que un bon endroit pour x
peut être un mauvais endroit pour y est
ce que on le sait alors ce soir
j'aimerais que nous quittant du bon
endroit et qu'on arrive à aller vers
notre endroit qui aiment les roms
n'hésitez pas à peut-être qu'on va
distribuer des visas ici on ne sait
jamais
qui aime l'europe n'est ce pas qu'on
aime d'europe c'est beau ça nous tente
mais je veux dire une vérité moi je
connais des gens j'ai vu des gens partir
en europe
revenir avec un grand succès j'ai vu nos
frères au mollet à lui étudier en europe
revenir avec des solutions revenir créer
des entreprises à succès ok alors en
voyant ça décape c'est sûr que c'est le
meilleur endroit l'europe c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle tout
le monde de partir il y en a qui partent
par de voir ma mort déplorable
pourquoi parce que en na'vi x partir et
revenir avec un succès en ce type voilà
c'est ça le l'endroit socialement mon
droit
mais je vais vous dire une vérité moi
j'ai encore eu des gens partir en europe
et revient dans un serveur christ n'est
ce pas cette europe là qui paraît très
mots ces mêmes europe la quittance j'ai
vu tout le monde surtout quand j'ai
parlé qu'on peut offrir des physiques si
j'étais tout france aso fois il ya un
mur dit le mot
ses passions se comprend c'est même
d'europe là que nous offrions mais on a
mis son parti et qui sont revenus dans
un cercueil pourquoi parce que tout
simplement ce n'était pas leur droit
parce que tout simplement il n'était pas
destiné à être là mais pourquoi il sont
partis c'est parce que d'après eux
c'était le bon endroit et après de tous
terre mais j'aimerais que ce soir qu'on
arrête de conclure que l endroit est un
bon endroit parce que nous voyons des
autres on n'a pas la même destinée on a
pas on n'est pas appelée à faire la même
chose si je suis appelé à réussir dans
un bureau peut-être vous vous êtes
appelés à réussir en brousse
j'entends quelqu'un dire sans effet mais
c'est en réalité c'est la réalité
on n'est pas appelée à faire la même
chose
alors parlons de cependant droit lorsque
nous parlons de cet endroit là vous
voyez vous êtes un lieu on est heureux
d'être ici mais c'est d'imaginer une
chose si on s'est même endroit en
apporter on a mené à un aveugle muet ils
nous voient pas une écoute pas penser
qu'il aura le même avis que vous pas du
tout qui ne voit rien et montre rien il
n'a pas besoin d'être ici il a besoin
d'être peut-être dans une école
habilités ou pas le monde
départ de gestes mais pendant ces temps
pour nous c'est à bon droit mais pas
pour lui j'aimerais que chacun de nos
abris à faire la part de choses sur ces
sujets pendant 3 lorsque vous allez les
copains je sais pas si ça vous est déjà
arrivé moi ça m'arrive de temps en temps
je pense d'adhésion de savoir essayer de
me montrer un bon moi je veux me
retrouver où je veux visiter et souvent
on me présente un lieu qui ne mettant
que moi je me pose la question mais en
cours c'est un beau diamant non droit
c'est là que je réalise qu on n'a pas
les mêmes erreurs que nous commettons
c'est dé conclure par rapport à ses
enfants les autres seafrance a réussi à
me lâcher
cela veut dire que moi aussi je peux
réussir mais s'il faut c'est faux nom
était venu avec son business
on l'a vu venir on est déjà d'ailleurs
mont lantin gré et si la réussite c'est
à dire que nous aussi bon si je peux me
lancer
ce n'est pas ça aujourd'hui nous voulons
quitter
alors lorsque je parle d' endroit je ne
tente pas seulement d'un lieu quel camp
je pense surtout d'un environnement
c'est important cet environnement ça
peut être des gens qui vous entourent
vous êtes entourés de qui nous avons
tous la situation du pays de l'afrique
en hausse et mais nous passons nos
journées à critiquer à critiquer oui
tout va mal ok oui on n'a pas de pouce
oui on n'a pas ça oui on a pas mais
c'est quoi la suite c'est quoi la suite
un legs ne peut pas traîner avec le
moineau j'ai vu continué à traîner avec
le moineau vous allez rester à ce niveau
là alors lorsque je suis encore nous
parler du bon endroit je vois le
l'environnement changé votre
environnement changer votre mode de vie
écoutez vous ne pouvez pas espérer avoir
des résultats différents
si vous ne faites que les mêmes choses
que les mêmes serrures regardez autour
de vous êtes vous entourer de gens qui
ont la même vision que vous ça pense
être entouré de gens qui vous
encouragent dans cette fête revient de
vos amis partagent de publication
combien mais pourquoi vous restez avec
des gens qui ne vous êtes pas ce soir on
va faire cet exercice on va quitter de
bons endroits pour chercher notre propre
endroit alors comment arriver à détecter
cet endroit c'est simple on va faire un
petit exercice on va juste fermer les
yeux
rassurez-vous war on est en sécurité
une seconde seulement
ne voyez pas la personne à côté de vous
ne voyez pas les gens qui vous entourent
ne voyez pas d'abord ceux qui ont réussi
je vais peut être vous choquer vous
allez me dire mais lydia attend c'est
important de devoir aussi les autres
c'est qu'ils font je n'en disconviens
pas mais je veux me dire quand est ce
que nous allons voir les autres là je
vais le dire tout de suite mais pour le
moment
regardons nous nous mêmes d'abord fermer
les yeux
chercher à aller au fond de vous paie
c'est tout le monde qui me regarde on a
peur on est pas on n'est pas sûr de son
voisin
ok essayons de le faire les yeux ouverts
essayer de rentrer au fond de vous-même
chercher votre vraie personnalité
chercher ce que vous voulez réellement
ne cherchez pas d'avancer que les autres
font ne cherchez pas d'abord à savoir
qu'est ce qu'il a fait pour réussir si
je dois faire mon nom maintenant on a
besoin de chercher cette frais personnes
qui ont fondu sortez moi ces
personnes-là définissez clairement ces
personnes je vais appeler ses parfums
une rédéfinition pourquoi la
redéfinition parce que nous nous
définissons par rapport aux autres noms
ont fait la table rase rédéfinition
maintenant cherchons c'est très
personnel c'est une vraie personnalité
ouvrez les yeux maintenant
je pense que vous avez vu ces personnes
je pense que vous avez vu clairement ce
que vous voulez de cette personne alors
qu'est ce que nous allons faire
maintenant
après avoir trouvé ce que nous voulons
réellement entre après avoir trouvé ce
que nous voulons réellement faire de
notre vie après avoir eu la vision
claire de ce que nous voulons être dans
le titre enchaîne famille c'est
maintenant qu'on va regarder autour de
regard donc qu'ils sont tous deux de ses
amies elle
pensez vous qu'ils sont les bonnes
personnes à vous aider à aider cette
personne que vous venez de découvrir les
bons c'est vous alors si vous ne pensez
pas changer votre courage votre mode de
vie votre style de vie
comment vous vivez lyonnais y en a qui
on veut être un grand dirigeant
mais pensez vous que ces grands
dirigeants peuvent vivre quand vous
vivez
pensez vous que ces grands dans cette
grande femme peut faire les choses que
vous faites
alors si vous ne pensez pas changé le
maintenant et c'est là votre monde
entourez vous de ces gens là qui vont
vous aider à aller de l'avant
je vous ai dit que les ennemis ne traîne
pas avec
cherchez des aigles au royal des gens
qui vont vous aider à voler plus loin
entouré de ses gens là mais ne soyez pas
pressés parce que c'est ce que nous
remarquons une fois concédé au fond ce
titre c'est bon là c'est fini je dois
partir je doive voler de mes propres
ailes mais vous avez peut-être besoin
d'être coaché rester avec ce genre à
traîner créé construisent et
déconstruisent de cette personne ce
n'est pas automatique
ça peut prendre du temps et soyez
patients attendez votre temps mais
rappelez vous quand même que vous êtes
dans votre endroit je dirais mieux dans
votre bon endroit
l'endroit que vous avez définies on sait
tous que l'avion doit décoller
on sait tous que vous avez c'est qu'il
faut pour dérouler attention l'avion ne
peut pas décoller n'importe où l'avion
ne peut pas décoller n'importe quand et
n'importe comment
et nous savons tous que lorsqu'il ya des
problèmes avec l'avion qu'est-ce qui se
passe crash et je veux vous dire une
vérité qui peuvent choquer dans la
plupart d'aucuns lui à grasse les gens
de s'en sortir à éviter ça
prenez le temps de vous découvrir prenez
le temps de vous construire
restez dans votre bon endroit ne vous
embrouiller pas foncé et le maire et
d'avenir je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]